Transcription: Nadine Hage Chehade
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonsoir à tous.
Alors on ne se connaît pas très bien,
et pourtant je vais quand même
vous demander quelque chose.
Je vais vous demander
à tous de fermer les yeux.
J'en vois pas mal
qui trichent pour l'instant.
Et malgré la lumière
je vous vois quand même,
donc fermez bien les yeux s'il vous plaît.
Super.
Alors, maintenant, je vais vous demander
de retrouver un moment dans votre vie
où vous aviez très envie
de faire quelque chose,
vous aviez envie d'essayer quelque chose
et quelqu'un vous a empêché de le faire
en vous disant, par exemple,
que vous étiez trop petit
ou que vous ne saviez pas faire.
Vous avez ce moment ?
J'aimerais que vous vous rappeliez
les émotions
que vous aviez ressenties à ce moment-là,
ce que vous ressentiez vraiment.
Vous étiez peut-être triste,
peut-être frustré,
peut-être même en colère.
Vous pouvez rouvrir les yeux.
Et si vous aviez pu faire
autrement à ce moment-là ?
C'est de ça qu'on va parler.
C'est un sujet qui est
très important pour moi,
et qui vous touche tous.
C'est la confiance en soi.
La confiance en soi, c'est cette sensation
intérieure de pouvoir réaliser nos désirs.
C'est elle qui nous permet d'agir.
C'est sentir qu'on est capable
de faire face au défi.
C'est ce qui nous permet d'apprendre,
de persévérer,
de faire des choix,
de prendre des décisions.
Une vieille étude de 1967,
d'un Américain, Stanley Copersmith,
explique ce qui induit la notion
de confiance en soi dans chacun.
C'est être élevé avec amour et respect,
avec des consignes claires,
sans contradiction,
sans oppression,
sans contraintes,
et à l'inverse, avec un certain nombre
de notions sur la bonne volonté,
sur la bonne nature de chacun.
La triste vérité, c'est que
chacun d'entre nous
a plus ou moins vécu l'inverse de ce qui
induit cette notion de confiance en soi.
Vous avez tous entendu :
« Tu es trop petit. »
« Tu ne sais pas faire. »
« Tu n'as pas les compétences. »
« C'est trop difficile pour toi. »
Dans mon activité, on nous demande
souvent, actuellement,
où est-ce que je trouve l'énergie,
où est-ce que je trouve
la motivation pour faire ça ?
On me dit souvent :
« Moi à ta place, j'en serais incapable. »
« J'en serais incapable. »
Cette phrase revient trop souvent
Cette phrase, ancrée en vous,
est une barrière que vous vous mettez,
plus ou moins dans différents domaines,
et qui vous empêche
de réaliser les choses.
Pourtant, les super héros n'existent pas,
et certains font de grandes choses
dans la vie, pourquoi ?
Simplement parce qu'ils ont réalisé
que les limites qu'ils
se donnent n'existent pas.
Alors, comme toutes les histoires
qui finissent bien
commencent par il était une fois,
je vais vous raconter une histoire.
Donc il était une fois un petit garçon
qui avait deux problèmes.
Le premier, c'est
qu'il ne savait pas nager.
Vous me direz que ce n'est pas
un très gros problème.
Le deuxième, c'est qu'il est très timide.
Il est incapable de parler
à quelqu'un ou à un inconnu
au point où demander l'heure à quelqu'un
ou demander un prix à
une vendeuse lui est impossible.
Il va envoyer sa sœur à la place.
Donc on va reprendre, un petit garçon,
il a 10 ans.
C'est les vacances d'été,
et il a la chance de
pouvoir partir à la mer,
15 jours à la mer avec ses parents.
Hyper chouettes, les vacances.
Sauf que lui le problème,
c'est qu'il ne sait pas nager.
Premier jour, il arrive.
Son père et sa sœur vont jouer dans l'eau.
Et lui se retrouve sur
la plage à les regarder,
et à être incapable de les rejoindre.
Alors qu'ils n'ont que de l'eau
jusqu'aux genoux,
il a trop peur de l'eau.
Et il va les regarder
toute la journée comme ça.
Deuxième jour, ils retournent à la plage.
Le problème recommence.
Il va les revoir toute la journée
sans pouvoir les rejoindre.
Trois jours, quatre jours,
quinze jours comme ça.
Vous imaginez un peu la frustration
de vivre quinze jours comme ça ?
Au retour des vacances,
la décision, elle est prise.
Il va convaincre ses parents de l'inscrire
au club de natation de la ville,
au cours de natation de la ville.
Et il a la chance de n'avoir que
10 ans, et à 10 ans, on apprend vite.
Donc en trois quatre mois,
il sait déjà nager.
En six mois, il nage aussi
bien que sa sœur.
Et à la fin de l'année, il va même
rentrer dans le club de natation local.
Et du coup, l'été suivant,
retour à la mer.
Il ira dans l'eau.
Un an plus tard, comme récompense
d'avoir franchi cette barrière,
il va même intégrer le sport études
et deux ans plus tard, il ramène
son premier titre de champion de France.
Seulement quatre ans après
cette plage qui l'aura retenu.
L'enfant grandit,
il devient adolescent, 17 ans.
Il continue de s'épanouir
dans la natation,
mais son problème de timidité subsiste.
Et à 17 ans, c'est l'année
du baccalauréat de Français.
Deux épreuves, l'écrit et l'oral.
Évidemment, avec
cette timidité qui restait,
l'oral va être difficile.
Et ce qui devait arriver arriva.
C'est un échec.
Impossible de dire le moindre mot.
Je ne vous donnerai pas de détails
de la note mais je vous laisse imaginer.
Il passe en terminale,
18 ans, l'âge de la maturité,
de la majorité, pardon,
et du baccalauréat.
Avec le retard, un petit peu,
qu'il a pris avec le Français,
avec des lacunes dans certaines matières,
ça s'annonce difficile.
Le premier résultat tombe :
9,5 de moyenne.
9,5 de moyenne,
ça implique le rattrapage.
Deux oraux à passer.
Alors les enseignants regardent
quelles matières il peut choisir,
comment il peut optimiser
ces quelques points qui lui manquent,
les 0,5 point de moyenne qu'il va
lui falloir pour obtenir son baccalauréat.
Mais le problème,
ce n'est pas les matières.
Le problème c'est, qu'une fois
de plus, il va falloir prendre la parole
devant ces inconnus,
répondre à des questions.
Et ce qui devait arriver arriva.
C'est de nouveau un échec,
et il n'aura pas son baccalauréat.
Alors, je vous laisse imaginer
un petit peu l'été suivant,
après ces deux échecs,
ne pas avoir eu son baccalauréat,
rester en terminale.
Il se met même à ressasser
tous les autres moments de sa vie
où il n'a pas pris la parole,
où il n'a pas su parler.
Et pourquoi ?
Par peur de dire une bêtise,
peur du regard des autres.
Comme huit ans auparavant,
il se décide à trouver une solution
et à vaincre sa timidité.
Alors comment on fait ?
Lui se décide à prendre un emploi
d'accompagnateur pour de jeunes enfants
où il va devoir prendre le micro
et prendre la parole,
leur expliquer des choses,
leur donner des consignes, etc.
Et qu'est-ce qu'il se passe ?
Eh bien, rien du tout.
Tout se passe bien.
Il parle, ils écoutent.
Parfois, il dit des bêtises,
il se rattrape.
Et finalement, l'année suivante,
il aura son baccalauréat.
Les années qui suivent,
il va passer d'autres entretiens
pour différentes filières d'études,
pour des entretiens de travail,
et tout va bien se passer,
au point où aujourd'hui,
il donne des cours avec des amphis
de 200 ou 300 étudiants sans problème.
Dans ces deux étapes, il était dos au mur.
Il était dans l'échec.
Il n'avait pas le choix, il fallait se
battre, il fallait franchir quelque chose.
Ce n'est pas toujours comme ça, parfois
c'est aussi un choix d'aller plus loin.
Du coup je vais vous raconter une dernière
étape de la vie de cette personne.
Il a 30 ans, il a arrêté de
nager à 18 ans, voilà ça fait 12 ans.
Il se décide à se remettre
à l'eau, par plaisir.
Trouver un club dans le coin
et il se remet à nager.
Après quelques mois,
un nageur lui parle d'un événement
qui s'appelle les 24 heures
de natation de Lausanne.
C'est un événement
qui a lieu tous les ans,
où toutes les personnes qui
en ont envie peuvent venir nager
la durée et la distance
qu'elles souhaitent.
On ne connaît pas la raison pour
laquelle ça aurait pu lui venir à l'idée,
mais une idée folle émerge :
et s'il durait l'intégralité
de l'événement, les 24 heures ?
Évidemment, quand il parle
de ça à son entourage,
les phrases qu'il entend
sont toujours les mêmes :
« C'est impossible, tu ne te rends
pas compte, c'est trop difficile. »
« Personne n'est capable de faire ça. »
Sauf que lui, il se rappelle
qu'il y a 10 ans,
quand il a fallu apprendre
à nager, il y est arrivé.
Quand il a fallu vaincre
sa timidité, il y est arrivé.
Alors pourquoi pas ?
Pourquoi pas ?
Il se met à s'entraîner.
L'événement est dans 6 mois,
ça lui laisse un peu de temps,
donc il se prépare.
Il s'entraîne et finit par
nager une heure, deux heures,
trois heures, quatre heures.
L'événement arrive.
C'est le samedi, il est 16 heures.
Il se met à l'eau.
Finalement, l'épreuve est plus
difficile que ce qu'il pense,
beaucoup plus, déjà parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de monde ;
il faut nager dans une ligne avec
20 ou 30 personnes, il prend des coups,
le froid, au bout de quelques heures,
c'est même la faim, l'ennui.
Ce n'est pas facile.
Il veut abandonner plusieurs fois.
Chaque fois qu'il veut abandonner,
que l'idée émerge dans sa tête,
il trouve l'énergie de se relancer,
au point où, finalement,
le lendemain matin, à 10 heures,
après 18 heures de natation,
18 heures dans l'eau,
il franchit le record
de l'épreuve, 56 kilomètres,
qui avait été fait 18 ans auparavant.
Il ne le savait même pas.
Il avait envie de sortir,
les organisateurs
lui demandent de continuer.
Et finalement, il nagera 21 heures 30
et parcourra 60 kilomètres.
Vous me direz : « Il n'a pas nagé
ce jour-là 24 heures. »
Non, mais il aurait peut-être pu.
En tout cas, il a compris
qu'il en était capable.
Et en fait, à tout objectif,
il faut faire des paliers.
Donc c'était son premier palier
et il y en aura d'autres.
Finalement, il nagera les 24 heures.
Au point même où deux ans plus tard,
après que quelqu'un lui a parlé
de l'idée de nager 48 heures,
il se lance le défi un peu fou
de nager 48 heures.
Quelque chose qui n'a jamais été réalisé
par aucun nageur, dans le monde entier.
Il prend le créneau, trois mois plus tard.
L'entraînement en fait
ne joue plus à ce moment-là.
Le mental prend le dessus
sur ce genre d'effort.
3 mois plus tard, il est au rendez-vous.
Il prend 15 jours de congé
sans toucher l'eau.
Il arrive le jour J et il se met à l'eau.
Alors je ne vais pas vous faire
les détails de toute cette épreuve-là,
mais sachez juste que, ce jour-là,
il va nager, alors ce n'est pas
ce jour-là,
c'est ce moment-là
parce que ça va durer deux jours,
il va nager 48 heures,
102 kilomètres avec un double
record du monde à la clé.
Donc c'était possible.
Cette histoire de ce petit garçon,
de cet adolescent, puis de cet adulte,
c'est la mienne,
mais c'est la vôtre.
Un jour, j'ai décidé d'oublier
que c'était impossible,
d'oublier que c'était difficile,
d'oublier que je ne savais pas faire.
Et j'ai essayé,
je me suis entraîné,
j'ai pris le temps,
jusqu'à réussir.
Je n'ai absolument rien de plus que vous.
Si moi j'y suis arrivé,
vous pouvez y arriver.
Si vous n'avez qu'une seule phrase
à retenir de tout ça,
ça serait la suivante,
une citation de Marc Twain :
« Ils ne savaient pas que
c'était impossible alors ils l'ont fait. »
Oubliez vos limites.
Oubliez vos barrières.
Croyez en vous, battez-vous
sans jamais baisser les bras,
et vous verrez, tout sera possible.
Tout deviendra possible.
L'impossible n'existe que
si vous le rendez possible,
alors rendez-le impossible,
croyez en vous.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)